التحويلات الوزاريه لماذا تاخرت في الايام
الاخيره من حكم بن علي ولماذا كانت غير
ذات اثر حقيقي
تاخرت هنالك تحويلات وزاريه كانت هم هم
ثلاثه
تحويل الاخير هو حل الحكومه يوم 13
هذا ربما كان معقولا لان المقترح في
الخطاب 13
حكومه يشارك فيها مختلف الاطراف ايه هذا
كان التوجه هو نحو هذا الاصلاح
ونداء معقول لكن تحويلات التي سبقتها
الاول في تغيير وزير الاعلام وزير الاعلام
كان تغيير الوجه الوزير الاعلام
لتفاعل اكثر
بشكل
مطالب كان اعلى بكثير بقطع النظر الى سقف
من الطالب استغلال كان هناك عمل على اعداد
للشيخ انا هنالك تكوين لاناس في الخارج
على استعمال الوسيط الاجتماعي على هذا كله
صار يعني هنالك ناس اخذوهم الى اماكن في
البوسنه وفي غيرها للتدرب على عده تاشيره
ولا حدث في تونس وحدث في مصر مثلا
بكل
الصوره وصوت اصبحت لها قيمه كبيره واليوم
لها قيمه اكبر يعني التوسع على الامر حتى
لو سلمنا جدولا بان ذلك حصل ولكن الظروف
في البلاد الم تكن تستدعي ذلك
المستدعته هو انه هنالك عمل الحكومي بدا
البحث عن مواد شغل جديده
لبعض الازمات في تلك الفتره غير الاوضاع
الاقتصاديه رغم ان تونس حافظ على نسبه نمو
جيده بالنسبه لغيرها ولكنها لم تكن كافيه
بالنسبه للطلب هذا صحيح هذه النقطه
والتحويل الثاني التحويل الثاني
معناها لو كنت مكان رئيس الجمهوريه لا
اغير على راسه وزاره الداخليه في في خلال
ازمه هل كان لديكم دلائل او براهين على ما
تفضلت به للتو من خلال تحدثنا عن هذا في
الحلقات الماضيه اقصد في موضوع همم يعني
تدريب وتمويل جهات بعينها في الداخل
التونسي شخصيا طلعت فيما بعد على وثائق
ذهب في مهمات الى الخارج لتدرب على اشياء
همم يعني همم الموضوع القناصه فيما بعد
تبين هذا اغلق لست ادري كيف همم انهم
جاءوا من الخارج كيف دخلوا من جاء بهم من
همم يعني هذه الاشياء هو مؤكد امنيا في
تونس موافق وتحدث عن وسائل الاعلام وربما
حتى همم التلفزات وكنت تعرضت للموضوع
عليها كما قلت في في في عده همم
يعني همم وسائل اعلاميه وفي وبعض شهود
وبعض من حضر في المطار وراء ابي عينه
وتكلم بان واشنطن تحديدا هي التي لا لا لا
هنا لا اتحدث عنه
مساله القناصه وغيره وغيرها ولكن انت قلت
في البدايه بانه كله كان مدار ومرتب مسبقا
كبير في العالم
منذ في النصف الثاني من القرن العشرين
وخصوصا بعد همم دخول في الالفيه الجديده
مصدر هو دائما هو القوه الاولى في العالم
التي هي الولايات المتحده
منذ اكثر من 220 سنه هي صديقه لتونس وتونس
صديقتهم سنوات